[Music]
my name is kat mcfadden and
i am a senior aquarist here at georgia
aquarium
and i have the privilege of working with
our ocean voyager exhibit
which is one of the largest aquatic
habitats in the world it's over 6.3
million gallons of temperate salt water
it's also home to some of the largest
fish in the world
including our four whale sharks and
three manta rays and
about 8 000 other smaller fish as well
a lot of people have asked what it takes
to
keep all of these animals happy and
healthy and on a day-to-day basis so
i thought i'd share with you guys just a
little glimpse of what my day looks like
in ocean voyager
follow me welcome to the deck of ocean
voyager
it is even bigger than it looks like
when you're down in front looking at all
the animals it is nearly the length of a
football field
and so we have all of those 6.3 million
gallons of salt water
and you can't see so well but behind
those walls is all the life support
systems
that it takes to keep that water clean
and comfortable for the animals that
live in here
so a tank has quite a bit of food that
we have to get through throughout the
day
uh he is a very large turtle we're
talking 400 pounds plus
and his entire diet is vegetarian
which means he eats a lot of lettuce he
also gets
cabbage today he's got some red cabbage
he also has some bok choy in there
we try to vary up the vegetables quite a
bit
but let me tell you this animal
definitely loves his salad
there are seven species of sea turtles
in the world every single one of them
are endangered green sea turtles are one
of my personal favorites
and tank is a great ambassador for his
species here
sea turtles can live very similar to a
human's life expectancy
80 years plus so he's got a home here
absolutely forever and ocean voyager is
a large enough habitat to accommodate
that
so our food is uh prepared for us every
single day by our wonderful commissary
team
and so this is tallulah's food right
here it's lula is our largest of the
three manta rays and on top we have her
vitamins ready so
even though tallulah is a very very
large fish
she actually eats really tiny foods this
is superb krill it's kind of like a
really tiny shrimp
and as you watch the manta feed you'll
see how we offer
that exact amount of food right to the
mantas in this huge habitat and one of
the tools that we use
is this large ladle on a stick so we can
put the food right in here
and every single one of our mantas knows
what color their ladle is so tallulah is
our blue ladle
and she will line up right to it and we
can offer that krill directly into her
mouth
i am convinced they are the smartest
fish out there they have one of the
largest brain to body ratios in the fish
world
they've got fantastic vision they have
learning ability
and we're really wanting to see kind of
what we can learn about their cognitive
abilities as well
and that's not something you
traditionally see with a lot of species
of fish but the mantas are
definitely in their their own genre
there they're fantastic
we are the only aquarium in north
america to house mantas here so
you're gonna get a very special
experience when you come to see them
even just seeing these animals in real
life i mean nothing compares to it
we have nearly 8 000 smaller fish in
here and we certainly don't forget them
every day too and you can see the
batfish know that it is feeding time
we are just over top of our large
theater viewing window
it is one of the largest aquatic viewing
windows in the world it's over 23 feet
tall
so hopefully the guests that are
standing right underneath me are going
to get a really nice view
and it looks like today we've got some
more gel food for them again this is a
super healthy diet it's got all the
vitamins that they need to keep their
color and their health up and you can
see all this reflection on the surface
of the water
that's not just the lights on the
exhibit we have a natural skylight in
here
that's really unique because it allows
our animals to get the sunlight get the
vitamin d and the uv rays that they need
for
overall health
just like our mantas we have these whale
sharks which are
very very large fish however they too
are eating super
tiny food here so if you look in those
bins you'll see very similar to what you
saw in the manta bin
we've got a lot of superb acryl we've
got some of that gel food in there
some vitamins we also have maybe some
small fish i see
layered down there in the bottom just to
make sure they get that
varied and nutritionally appropriate
diet
and i've talked a few times about when
we have so many animals
making sure that they all know where to
go to get their food is very important
the whale sharks are absolutely no
exception to that
so each of our feeders they go to a
specific line and each whale shark
knows where their boat is and what their
ladle is so
right now you are watching you sean e
he's got a red ladle
and kayla is feeding him on the second
line over
the whale sharks definitely go through
quite a bit of krill
so even though their food is very small
they still need to eat
quite a lot of it we're looking at up to
50 pounds of food a day per whale shark
and they're still growing whale sharks
despite their name they
are true sharks however they are the
largest fish in the ocean
they'll usually hit just over 30 feet
even the record sizes can get a lot
bigger than that
so these are very large fish and it
takes uh
quite a bit of food to keep them happy
and satiated
i've talked to many guests who they see
these whale sharks and they ask if
they're whales and when they find out
nope they're sharks that can be kind of
a scary thing a
shark that is that big however
these are incredibly docile creatures
despite their ginormous size that huge
mouth
the only thing they care about is
plankton that
is about this big i'm hoping that by
coming to the aquarium and
seeing all of our beautiful creatures
that
our guests will start to just get an
idea of
how unique and varied and what is
out there in these oceans and even by
changing
one small thing that we do in our
day-to-day routines whether that's
making sure that we're recycling or
being mindful
of our carbon emissions even just taking
a carpool that can have collectively a
huge impact
not only on the ocean but on all these
animals that live in it
i'm truly thankful that you got to join
me for a glimpse into our routine
every day at ocean voyager and i
encourage you to come visit us in person
let us share these beautiful creatures
with you and if you can't make it in
person
that's okay too visit our website at
georgiaaquarium.org
and take a look at all the virtual
offerings that we have available for you
as well
thanks have a great day
[Music]
you